hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
one key concept to certain Kierkegaard's
work fear and trembling it's really one
of the most core ideas is what he calls
a teleological suspension of the ethical
and when you first hear that or when you
first read it at the beginning of
problema one you may well say to
yourself this is a lot of jargon I I
don't understand what he is trying to
get across in asking this very question
that begins the problema
is there a teleological suspension of
the ethical and he brings it up at that
several points he also does explain what
this term means and he requires us to
face up to what we might call a key
decision about whether it's even
possible or coherent or whether it's not
in which case there are some very
important implications not only for the
Abraham story but for faith in general
and the relationship between religion
and ethics so let's start with this term
Telos this is a Greek word that in in
the text is actually kept in the Greek
and Telos is the word that we get
teleological from teleological
pertaining to the telus and it's hello's
is an end or a goal or a purpose so when
for example I asked my class the first
day of a new semester why are you here
I'm asking them for a Telos and they may
give me an answer like well my advisor
told me I need to take this intro to
philosophy or ethics or whatever other
class it happens to be and that's good
we have now an end a purpose a goal and
we have some sort of means or some way
to get there and the means is relative
to the end the mean
has value in relation to the end by the
way is a little bit of digression
sometimes people throw out this does the
end really justify the means and the
answer is in most cases yes that's the
whole point of having and the end a
Telos if you say to yourself I'm going
to get a birthday present for so-and-so
and somebody says well why the hell are
you spending money on that there's
probably some tell those to it it might
it might not be a great tellest it could
be well I want to get in good with them
so that they'll help me find a job you
know something rather tawdry and
commercial or it could be oh I want to
bring joy to them or it could be a
number of other different reasons but
what we do as human beings the
activities that we engage in are
purposive they have tell they have tell
a that's the plural for it and we can
think about how we arrange these in
relation to each other and so the
ethical is going to be very much shot
through with a Telos so Kierkegaard
tells us he begins by saying the ethical
is such is the universal as the
universal it applies to everyone and
then he says this also means it doesn't
just apply to everyone right now it
applies at all times if something truly
is an ethical norm we think that it
applies to everybody at least those who
are in you know those sorts of
circumstances at all times in the future
in the past in the present so he says it
rests imminent in itself now what does
that mean imminent in itself that it has
its meaning there within itself it says
it has nothing outside of itself that is
its Telos its end or purpose but is
itself the Telos for everything outside
itself and this is a very important
point that we should linger up when
somebody says well why should I be
ethical that's a sign that they are
asking for a talos outside of the
ethical so in for example business at
we try to make the case quite often that
well if you behave in an ethical manner
it's going to improve your bottom line
and that's not entirely bad or wrong but
it it makes teaching ethics a bit more
difficult doesn't it because it does
give the impression that the reason why
we want to be ethical the reason why
ethics matters why we should teach it
why we should study it why we should
learn it why should we should apply it
is so that we can make a lot of money or
the corporation that we're working for
can make a lot of money and if you're
saying something like that that becomes
the Telos then in that case you could
talk about a teleological suspension of
the ethical but to a lesser value
there's a Mis comprehension going on
there so properly understood the ethical
does not have a Telos outside of itself
it is what provides the Telos to
everything else outside of itself why do
we do art well there's gonna be some
reason within the realm of ethics that
can place that in proper context why
should we take our medicine why should
we take this class all of this according
to Kierkegaard could be placed within
the framework of the ethical he goes a
little bit further with this he says the
single individual sense ain't lien
psychically qualified an immediacy is
the individual who has his Telos his and
his purpose his goal his meaning we
might say in the universal and what does
this mean this means that the individual
has to align him or herself with the
moral demands of the ethical or they are
wrong or they are bad or they are let's
just call it evil because that's a term
that he uses here taking this by the way
from you know reading Hegel so he goes
on and he says the ethical task of the
individual is to continually express
himself in this in the goal to annul his
singularity in order to become the
universal as soon as the single
individual is
hurts himself in a singularity before
the universal he sins he does wrong he
fails morally speaking and only by
acknowledging this can he be reconciled
again with the individual so let's take
a why should you not lie because lying
is in general wrong and we can get into
all sorts of like limit cases about well
what about in this case and what about
that case but just start with in general
lying is wrong most of the time that we
transgress that it's not because we're
trying to save a whole maternity room
full of babies that are about to be
killed by the axe murder it's not these
thought experiments that philosophers
like to bring up it's because we don't
want the truth to come out for one
reason or another usually because of how
screwed up we ourselves are motives that
we don't acknowledge or if we do
acknowledge we allow them to dominate
ourselves and insofar as we do that we
transgress that norm we do not fulfill
the Telos and if we want to fulfill that
Telos then we have to say I did the
wrong thing and I'm going to make it
right and in the case of lying it might
be publishing a retraction or telling
the truth and publicizing the truth in
some other way or making a resolution
not to lie again doing the work that
would be involved to actually have
access to the truth if one lied because
of sloppy thinking or not dealing with
one's emotions well or anything along
those lines so then this is all fairly
straightforward and helps you understand
how it is that the Telos within Ethics
functions as the end the goal within
ethics so how do we get to a
teleological suspension well let's go on
a little bit further he says if this is
the highest that can be said of man and
his existence that the individual should
align him or herself with the universal
and insofar as they don't they are
engaged against some sort of moral
failure or sin
then he says the ethical is of the same
nature as a person's eternal salvation
now that may sound very theological to
you but here you should read this in
terms of the highest value whatever it
is that is best would be contained in
the ethical whatever it is that if we
were properly functioning human beings
we would naturally want to align
ourselves with would be contained in the
universal
so we're posed with a key question here
is the ethical the absolute highest is
it the ceiling so to speak is it the
divine as he goes on to say could be
looked at as a perspective and and was
in fact a perspective for paganism is it
one's eternal salvation if so then the
night of infinite resignation is the
best person that you can possibly be
or the tragic hero or any of the other
figures that he talks about in that way
like Socrates for example so if that's
the case then there's no way to have a
teleological suspension of the ethical
because you can't get a Telos outside of
the ethical any tell us that would be
outside of the ethical would be below
the ethical so if it's money or its
beauty or it's some other impulse that
would be below the ethical and you would
be not teleologically suspending but you
would be taking the wrong Telos right
but and here's the key thing if the
ethical is not the highest this is the
thought that many people can't even wrap
their heads around necessarily at some
point in time if it's not then the
ethical can be teleologically suspended
meaning that it can be made relative to
something above it to use that metaphor
of the ceiling if there really is a
sealing of the ethical are there cracks
within the ceiling that lets some light
come in from above something higher
something greater something more
valuable something that Trump's the
ethical Abraham's story if it's going to
be about faith turns on that very point
so he says that which is suspended is
going to be not not just relinquished
but preserved in the higher which is
it's its Telos and the question is how
that can happen he also talks about and
this is something that I put a little
bit lower here that what Abraham's story
shows us and what faith shows us and
what thinking about other people in this
similar situation is that if there is a
teleological suspension of the ethical
this is because there is a paradox which
he calls faith that the single
individual is higher than the universal
so normally we should subordinate
ourselves to the universal and in doing
so we would find our full purpose there
the meaning of our lives there the the
true value to which we would sacrifice
other things like maybe our own
personality or our prospects but there's
also a possibility that there could be
something higher than that and we could
relate to that as individuals and that
is indeed what he says the Abraham story
reveals to us he says by means of the
universal the single individual who as
the single individual becomes superior
they are in relation to the absolute and
absolute relation to the absolute well
let's talk about the Abraham story says
the story of Abraham contains just such
a teleological suspension of the ethical
and he talks
all the different interpretations that
scholars have come up with which attempt
to try to say that Abraham is somehow
still within the ethical or that you
know maybe it's just short-circuited at
this this particular time and none of
those really work he says he says what
their wisdom amounts to is the beautiful
proposition that basically everything is
the same everything can be made into an
analogy and he says this doesn't really
work why not
because Abraham acts by virtue as of the
absurd it is precisely the absurd that
he is the single individual is higher
than the universal there is no mediation
possible and he says listen what is the
ethical what is this this highest value
that should be observed for Abraham says
in ethical terms Abraham's relation to
Isaac is quite simply this the father
shall love the son more than himself and
we can come up with other things as well
and this is where the tragic hero comes
in who we don't really need to talk to
at this point
but there is an ethical norm that
Abraham doesn't seem to be following in
following God's command - or request or
however you wanna frame it to sacrifice
Isaac he is transgressing the ethical
and if there isn't any teleological
suspension of the ethical then Abraham
is either insane or a horrible murderer
and we shouldn't look to him at all
Kierkegaard tells us that Abraham does
in fact transgress the ethical but he
does so in in favor or motivated by a
higher Telos he says there's a higher
tellus outside of the ethical in
relation to which he suspended it and
this cannot be made universal you can't
say well everyone should behave the way
Abraham did because then it would go it
would go back within the realm of the
ethical instead we have to recognize
that
we think that there is a teleological
suspension of the ethical there are
cases where the ethical isn't enough and
it requires being given a Telos outside
of itself that puts everything else into
context that preserves while at the same
time transgressing the ethical and he
asks how does the single individual
reassure himself that he's legitimate
can he say well you know Kierkegaard
told us there's a teleological
suspension of the ethical so therefore
you know there's one for me no because
that again would be to make it Universal
it has to be looked at on a case-by-case
by case basis that can't be turned into
something like a program so again
another key part of this the individual
is placed in an absolute relation to the
absolute what is going on in this is
that something higher than the ethical
is being acknowledged and the ethical is
being suspended at this point in this
context for this person in relation to
that higher thing which in this case is
God and God's requests or command of
Abraham
you